chers amis baleri l'a rappelé souvent
lorsque nous parlons des régions nous
disons les régions failli parce que nous
faisons l'amalgamme il ya là une le
petit point bleu là haut
comme le dit un une radio qui en parlent
en parlant de la petite tache bleue
c'est l'alsace je voudrais d'abord vous
dire qu'en ce qui me concerne
sur ces six années qui viennent de
passer aux cinq ans qui viennent de
passer
depuis les dernières élections
régionales ce qui me frappe le plus
concernant les socialistes et leurs
relations aux régions c'est l'immense
mensonges du gouvernement sur la place
que vont occuper les régions on peut
être régionalistes ou pas on peut être
plus ou moins des centres et des
décentralisateur j'en suis mais affirmer
comme ils l'ont fait que les régions
vont demain être un pilier dans
l'organisation territoriale et les mains
sacré comme ils l'ont fait c'est juste
insupportable
jamais dans notre pays deux pics que la
décentralisation est engagé et je le dis
devant jean pierre raffarin jamais aucun
gouvernement a si peu fait jamais en
fait aucun gouvernement n'a tourné le
dos comme ils l'ont fait aux régions
j'étais vous le savez bien par la force
des choses dans l'association des
régions de france
je vous garantis que de temps en temps
j'ai été amené moi à me tourner vers eux
pour leur dire n'oubliez pas c'est moi
l'opposant car leurs critiques à
l'endroit du gouvernement sur la
politique de décentralisation et sur les
régions
ces critiques étaient tellement fortes
que même quelqu'un de l'opposition était
temps en temps à mener à leur dire
revenons aux réalités le gouvernement a
failli mais alors totalement failli en
matière de décentralisation en matière
de régionalisation et ce ne sont pas des
gesticulations de redécoupage qui vont
faire oublier cette faillite fondamental
dans la réorganisation des pouvoirs de
notre pays
nous savons que la responsabilité va
nous revenir à nous de faire en sorte
que la décentralisation est les pouvoirs
territoriaux soit une occasion de re
donner une nouvelle impulsion à la
france car la réforme de la france
passera par une réussite de la
décentralisation
ils ne l'ont pas réussi au contraire ils
ont sapé les fondements de la
décentralisation
tout à l'heure nous avons entendu en
particulier christian estrosi nous
parler de ce bilan socialiste mais aussi
tout ce que nous prépare cette alliance
plus ou moins voulu entre les
socialistes et le front national ont
fait en sorte de laisser entendre que
finalement tout a été fait juste vous
dire le cas lorsqu'on 2010 mon équipe
tout ensemble a pris les responsables
étaient au niveau de l'alsace nous
avions les mêmes défis la date était
élevé parce que nous avons investi en
particulier pour amener deux tgv
jusqu'en alsace
le tgv est et le rat rhône
mais l'engagement que nous avions pris
était premièrement de ne pas augmenter
la fiscalité je vais vous le dire on n'a
pas augmenté d'un euro
on n'a pas augmenté d'un euro
nous avons pris l'engagement dans cette
situation de stabiliser la dette nous
avons stabilisé la dette
nous avons pris l'engagement de ne pas
augmenter les dépenses de fonctionnement
et notamment personnel à périmètre
constant
notre personnel a diminué nous avons
pris l'engagement de faire en sorte de
continuer à faire l'investissement
puisque l'investissement c'est la
modernisation de la région est du pays
nous avons maintenu l'investissement on
l'a même augmenté ces deux dernières
années voilà la réalité chers amis c'est
à dire que au niveau de ces régions
si la volonté est là et si nous voulons
maintenir les engagements qui sont pris
nous avons la possibilité de le faire
trop souvent nos concitoyens nous
regardent en disant c'est des promesses
je veux d'une certaine façon vous dire
que lorsqu'on a la volonté de faire nous
pouvons tracer le chemin
je vous confirme qu en alsace la
dépenses de personnel et à 20% en
dessous de la moyenne nationale mais je
vous confirme aussi que le nombre
d'apprentis est tabac pour cent au
dessus de la moyenne nationale
je vais vous dire aussi chers amis
qu'au niveau des thés verts les trains
express régionaux
la régularité de cette race là dire les
trains qui arrivent à l'heure c'est à
dire les trains qui n'ont pas plus de
cinq minutes de retard ou d'avancé
le taux de régularité est à 96 7%
je vais vous dire en passant que bien
entendu la fiscalité locale doit payer
le complément au niveau du transport
puisque les billets ne suffisent pas
pour payer le fonctionnement des trains
alors que la moyenne nationale se situe
entre 20 et 25% des recettes qui
viennent des billets en alsace en 2014
nous sommes à 36% je veux dire
simplement mesdames et messieurs que
nous les républicains avec nos alliés
les centristes nous pouvons réussir
demain ce pari de dire que notre pays
qui se trouvent dans des situations
difficiles de crise que nous n'avons pas
connu depuis 50 ans eh bien les
collectivités peuvent être un atout une
chance un soutien pour sortir de cette
crise
oui les collectivités ce n'est pas un
poids mort qu'il faut punir les
collectivités doivent être une occasion
de re dynamiser et bien c'est cette
démonstration que nous les républicains
nous devons faire à tous ces pays à tous
ces territoires qui ont été gouvernée
par la gauche et qui demain doivent se
retrouver tout simplement pour l'avenir
de ces régions et pour l'avenir de la
france au niveau des républicains et au
niveau de l'alliance entre la droite et
le centre
car il y va permettez-moi de le dire que
la réforme de la france
il va aussi tout simplement de l'espoir
que nous devons donner aux français
voilà ce qui aujourd'hui est devant nous
redonner espoir redonner confiance à
l'ex sérieux avec efficacité et nous
serons demain
regardez tous ensemble dans la même
direction
parce que nous savons
que la réforme de notre pays parce que
nous savons que l'avenir de notre pays
c'est avec les républicains que nous
allons le construire